أريد أن أعرض لكم بعض مقاطع الفيديو التي
حصلنا عليها منذ ساعات فقط، وتُظهر
تلك الأسطوانة الفضية على الأرض
بالقرب من رئيس الوزراء الياباني،
ثم ترى أحد أفراد التفاصيل الأمنية وهو
يركلها بعيدًا عن الطريق
ثم ينشر بعضًا منها  نوع من
أجهزة الدرع هي محاولة للحفاظ على سلامة
رئيس الوزراء وكما
ذكرنا لحسن الحظ أنه بخير ولكن
لدينا اجتماعات مجموعة السبع تعقد هنا في
طوكيو ثم لدينا مؤتمر أكبر لمجموعة السبع
سيعقد قريبًا الشهر المقبل في
هيروشيما إنه أمني  من الواضح أنه
سؤال بغض النظر عما حدث ولكنه
الآن في دائرة الضوء، إنها قضية
تناولها رئيس الوزراء مؤخرًا، استمع إلى تعليقاته، جداول
الأحداث مثل قمة مجموعة السبع التي
اجتمع فيها كبار الشخصيات من جميع أنحاء العالم،
وأعتقد أن اليابان على الصعيد الوطني سيتعين عليها
العمل معًا  وبذل أقصى الجهود
لتوفير الأمن والأمان